today's video uh we got uh skippy who's
back part three did you carry hot sauce
in the back
what do we do yeah oh no no these like
do you do these
um a lot of people like to dip them in
our sweet barbecue sauce but
we do have friends or yeah you're a
branch
that's what i like what's your name
again cali okay so
uh kelly is our server okay so
um so we've arrived at rib city here
i've got all three of us in
so we've arrived at rip city this guy
may be the
most obnoxious vlogger i've ever seen
he's been doing this for maybe like a
decade
and this is cringe bro you know the
waitress there's like oh why am i on
camera right now
this [ __ ] better tip me and you
know skippy was like here's a
skippy whistle hey one skippy
video a day keeps the women away
and we have just gotten served our food
and this is what did you get
chicken fry or chicken tender tender
basket
okay and i got this which i've been
craving
this stuff since the last time i was
here no no skippy skippy no
you've been craving and we can
feel the thirst and um so anyways
we're here and this is our waitress what
do you think of us as a couple
what do you think of us as a couple what
what do you think of us as a couple
what the what do you think of us as a
couple
huh what do you think of us as a couple
what do you think of us as a couple what
do you think of us as a couple
what do you think of us as a couple
what do you think of us as a couple oh
dude all right
um oh
go ahead oh i have nothing to go ahead
on
i'm just i'm just simmering down so
you want something oh this one is good
you know what i mean but the opposite
it's like
it takes the spot yeah i mean and here i
am with no spot
god damn
oh wow dude hey guys be sure to like
comment and subscribe if you're enjoying
today's video
we're going to be coming back to you
guys five to six times a week including
live streams
so i mean yo just like the videos help
us out with the algorithm the more we
grow
the more we can make for you the more
you can spend time watching album preach
you know what i mean what you mean some
people are not subscribed
apparently not some people are not
liking either they're enjoying it
they're commenting
they're tuning in please just hit smash
the like button
so you're just gonna act like you don't
like that [ __ ] you that's what you're
gonna do you want to act like you're not
liking it
but you watch it every day every night
great why are we just going for each
other
okay now regardless of regardless of how
much i tip you
what's your honest opinion it's like you
know she said good you could have left
it at that
you know that you're detestable i don't
know for sure but i don't think he lacks
self-awareness
he knows he knows he just digs into the
cringe
he knows the cringe work might as well
just go alway
full cringey then just ignore it you
know
you know he got it you got it skippy you
got us let's say i was to give you like
uh
a 50 cent tip would you what would your
still honest opinion about
as a couple
if you saw us walking down the street
would you be like i get that or like
would you be like he's way lucky or
would you be like she's way lucky
okay i'm good you know you know what
you're doing bro
that's it you're so coercive like the
way that you engage in these dates is
just basically to corner a woman to make
her as uncomfortable as possible
so that she'll pity be with you it's
it's very gross and disgusting yup
let's stop thinking that he doesn't know
and he's oblivious it's not that well
i'm pretty sure in the first episode we
labeled him a toxic person
yes yes yes yes that's a hard question
[Music]
this might even make it to the youtube
oh my gosh are you okay with that
maybe even put it on facebook yeah i'll
tag you
okay so when somebody is working at a
restaurant and they live off of tips
and you're making what they what they
consent to sound conditional
of course that consent is kind of void
people who are working want to get their
money so when you say like yeah i might
upload it you're going to be okay with
that you don't mind if i put on facebook
some people are going to feel
uncomfortable when you ask them before
you've even tipped them or paid them
kind of stands to reason that they're
probably not going to give you the most
honest answer and you don't see that
so you to me just it strikes me you
don't care no you know and you're fine
with coercing people
and even the date she's getting
uncomfortable with it
i'll tag you with that okay so um
all right uh we'll move we'll uh move on
with the conversation and stuff but uh
let her go back to work yeah we'll enjoy
our meal all right
thanks kelly that was kelly
[Music]
yeah so we got on a date with her
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this guy bragging i'm on a date
with her look guys she's just trying to
eat her fries
because that's the thing is that that's
how he gets dates because at the end of
the day he wants dates and maybe
something will happen but he gets a date
he gets to not spend that much time with
his mom
he gets to spend time with another girl
awkward or not he's gonna decide to
spend that time with her
and he spends it and that that's it so
i'm gonna just say that some people
deserve to die alone i hope
he does i hope he dies a lot okay so me
calling people trash is not good but you
wishing people die alone
there's a difference between me watching
behavior over a 10-year period which is
what this youtube channel of his is
him doing this to multiple women being
told in every comment section that he is
wrong
and then him continuing that behavior
and then doubling and tripling and
quadrupling down
so there's a difference so are you
saying there's a difference so are you
saying that he's trash
no i'm not gonna use that word you wanna
use that word that's fine i said if he
dies alone i don't feel bad
because his actions directly contribute
to him deserving to be alone
if you go into every relationship okay
and then you say
i don't care about your needs i'm going
to try to coerce you into giving me what
i want irrespective of how that makes
you feel
then to me yeah you're trash okay i said
you had me
i said it are you happy you want me to
say the word trash so bad
does that feel good does it feel good
right in there huh and you're a little
trash mark
huh huh what do you have there a
dumpster fire where your heart should be
yes okay yeah he's crashed okay i said
it i mean god damn how much evidence do
you need
if you kill 30 people uh you trash sorry
you don't have to be sorry
yeah yeah yeah anyways that's what i
said it's more fun
you're good who you triggered oh man
goddamn yeah
he got to you this is one of those
things where i'm just like ugh
but it is an earth moment if he is
unaware which he's not
it's trash because numerous people have
told him you know what i mean
and if he's aware it makes it worse he's
too manipulative he's too manipulative
to be unaware
yes exactly he knows what he's doing so
i don't feel bad for him at all so when
he did that thing
the whistle thing he knew exactly what
he was doing he's been uploading these
awkward videos for years people have
been telling him to stop
he knew exactly what he was doing even
just recently put on a new live stream
he's like i'm going to lose my
bruh no you're not and i hope you never
do pay for it
pay for it and pay her a lot of money
because anybody who chooses to do that
with you
she deserves sympathy that's my thoughts
on him anything else you want to say
is there something else to say i don't
know jesus christ nah i mean i'm good
what do you think about him
i already done that trash i've done some
trash
say it loud he's stretching his wack
[Music]
foreign